Ben what do you think it means to be a
conservative what's what's the
philosophy that underlies your political
view so first of all I'm glad that
Destiny you're already coming out as a
republican that's exciting um I mean I I
we hold a lot in common in terms of uh
you know the the basic idea
that people ought to have as much
opportunity as possible and also in so
far as the government should do the
minimum amount necessary to interfere in
people's lives in order to pursue
certain functions particularly at the
local level so a lot of governmental
discussions on a pragmatic level end up
being discussions about where government
ought to be involved but also at what
level government ought to be involved
and I have an incredibly subsidiary view
of government I I think that you know
local governments because you have
higher levels of homogenity and and
consent uh are capable of doing more
things and as you abstract up the chain
it becomes more and more impractical and
more and more divisive to to do more
things in in my government is basically
there to preserve certain key Liberties
uh the those key Liberties pre-exist the
government uh in in so far as they are
more important than what priorities the
government has the the job of government
is to maintain for example National
Defense protection of property rights
protection of religious freedom and the
these are these are the key focus of
government as generally expressed in the
Bill of Rights and the Constitution and
I agree with the general philosophy of
the Bill of Rights and the Constitution
now that doesn't mean by the way that
you can't do more on a governmental
level again as you get closer to the
ground which by the way is also embedded
in the Constitution people forget the
Constitution was originally applied to
the federal government not to local and
state governments um but you know if I
going to Define conservatism it would
actually be a little broader than that
because I think to understand how people
interact with government you have to go
to kind of core values and so for me
there there are a couple of premises one
human beings have a nature that nature
is neither good nor bad we have aspects
of goodness and we have aspects of
Badness human beings are sinful we have
temptations and what that means is that
we have to be careful not to incentivize
the bad and that we should incentivize
the good human beings do have agency and
are capable of making decisions in the
vast majority of circumstances um and it
is better for a society if we act as
though they do uh second the basic idea
of human nature there is an idea in my
view that all human beings have equal
value before the law I'm I'm a religious
person so I'd say equal value before God
but I think that's also sort of a key
tenant of Western Civilization being
nonreligious or religious that every
individual has equivalent value in sort
of cosmic terms um but that does not
necessarily mean that every person is
equally equipped to do everything
equally well and so it is not the job of
government to rectify every imbalance of
Life The Quest for Cosmic justice as
Thomas Soul suggests is something the
government is generally incapable of
doing and more often than not botches
and makes things worse so those are a
few key tenants and that that tends to
materialize in in a variety of ways the
the the the easiest way to sum that up
would the traditional kind of three
lives of the the conservative stool
although now obviously there's a very
fragmented conservative movement in the
United States would be a a socially
conservative view in which family is the
chief institution of society like the
little platoon of society as Edmond
Burke suggested uh in which free free
markets and property rights are
extraordinarily valuable and necessary
uh because every individual has the
ability to be creative with their
property and to freely
alienate that property uh and uh and
finally I tend toward a hawkish foreign
policy that suggests that the world is
not filled with wonderful people who all
agree with us and think like us and
those people will pursue adversarial
interests if we if we do not protect our
own
interest